moi je vais vous interroger sur
plusieurs points le premier c'est
lorsque vous avez eu à faire face à
l'épidémie de grippe
[Musique]
lorsque vous êtes ministre
est ce que vous avez ressenti la
nécessité de vous entourer d'une
expertise scientifique indépendante
telle l'actuel conseil scientifique ou
comment aviez vous fonctionnez quels
étaient les les agences ou organismes ou
direction qui est à vos côtés pour vous
accompagner dans la prise de décision
sachant qu en effet la prise de décision
est toujours politique
le deuxième point c'est sûr la situation
passée récente est celle actuelle des
personnes âgées en ehpad vous avez
lorsque vous êtes ministre lancé un
grand chantier de la dépendance je sais
que c'est un sujet auquel vous êtes
attachés et sur laquelle vous avez un
regard qui nous intéresse
calé vous comme non pas communisme comme
citoyenne ce que vous avez ressenti dans
la gestion passés au niveau 2 des ehpad
comment comment ont été prises en compte
les personnes âgées est ce qu'il ya des
éléments que l'on pourrait corriger dans
ce qui a pu se passer et le troisième
point c'est sur les agences régionales
de santé
lorsqu'on a fait les auditions on a vu
dans certains départements ou régions et
notamment peut-être les régions qui sont
restés plus de taille plus modeste
les relations entre les ars les élus et
les préfets se sont parfois très bien
passé mais dans d'autres cas il ya eu
des dissensions entre préfectures et ars
des ars avec les antennes
départementales parfois absentes qu'elle
serait puisque ça va faire partie des de
nos préconisations ci de travailler sur
l'organisation des soins
quel serait selon vous les les
modifications apportées à la situation
actuelle des agences régionales de santé
je vois que ce ne sont pas des questions
qui vous conviennent mettez
micro allez-y c'est la ministre je
rappelais une position principe je suis
là dans une commission denquête qui me
demandent des comptes sur la gestion de
l'épidémie de 2009 sur des faits rien
que des faits je ne suis pas là en tant
que citoyenne pour apporter des opinions
je suis désolé ce n'est pas le rôle
d'une commission denquête je ne suis pas
là je le répète pour savoir les pour
vous indiquer les transformations que je
voudrais donner aux ars
je suis désolé ce n'est pas ma fonction
actuelle
donc je réponds sur l'épidémie de 2009
et sur ma politique
soyons clairs alors vous m'avez posé des
questions très précises
madame elle aimait je vais même la
ministre
c'est une commission d' enquête sur le
co lead voilà voilà
vous avez une expérience utile de mon
expérience qui peut être utile à
l'analyse de des sénatrices et des
sénateurs de cette commission qui en
maintenant des dizaines et des dizaines
d'heures de réflexion sur le sujet en
conséquence des questions sont précises
posées par le rapporteur notamment sur
le besoin d'avoir une organisation
scientifique quand on est ministre on
est décision vous pouvez répondre à des
pris des décisions sur les
réorganisation territoriale dairay co2
répondre je pense que sur les ehpad
également vous avez une expérience qui
permet de voir comment on traite la
crise aujourd'hui par rapport aux
décisions d'hier mais également quel est
votre sentiment contenu de votre
position de ministre de la santé il est
sûr que on est dans un exercice continue
de l'évolution actuelle délicat
il y à un certain nombre de réserves
nous pouvons le comprendre néanmoins je
pense que les questions de catherine des
rôles sont tout à fait pertinente et
relevant de la commission denquête
permettez-moi de le dire
alors si maintenant je vous repasse la
parole il ya effectivement des questions
auxquelles je vais répondre sur ce qui
concerne la gestion de la crise
[Musique]